what is going on everybody welcome to
the 12th financial charting tutorial
within Python and matplotlib where we
left off I'll just bring up an example
of the chart that we've got we left off
with the chart basically like this so
fundamentally I mean this chart is
pretty much done as far as candlestick
and volume chart is concerned I mean
we've got all the necessities that we
need now before we start taking our
chart to the next level with like moving
averages are like MACD and all that kind
of stuff
a little known tactic to making extra
money is to make your chart badass right
so if you do Forex you're gonna get a
few extra pips if your chart looks just
really cool right and if you're
investing you're gonna make just a
little bit more money if your chart
looks good so it's really just
imperative that we make this chart look
badass so what I'd like to do is we're
gonna change I think what we'll do is
we'll move off of bars down here and
make it you'll see it'll be pretty cool
and then we're just gonna change some
colors around a bit mostly I just want
to show you guys all of the options that
are available to you guys I'll show you
like how you would change them if you
wanted to obviously we'll be doing it in
the video so you can follow along and
see but you know you might want to do
something else entirely you know you
might want to change your own colors and
so I'll just show you guys exactly how
to do that and then we'll end up
changing this chart and honestly the one
that we're gonna change into is probably
pretty awesome-looking so I can't
imagine why you'd want to do anything
other than what I show you but I'm going
to teach you guys how to do it so with
that let's go ahead and hop in so a few
of the things I like really we're not
gonna change anything up here we don't
need more imports or anything like that
so go ahead and scroll down and
basically all of our edits for like the
next for this entire chart are gonna
kind of like pap in-between here you
know like the everything is going to be
within these few lines so let's see the
first thing that we want to do is figure
probably the first step to making
anything bad ass is blacking it out
right if you want to make your car
about us you black it out right you
darken everything that you can so that's
what we're gonna start doing but one of
the things to keep in mind is at least
with like graphs if you literally turn
everything black it kind of looks weird
you cut you don't want to do like just
like a pitch black you kind of want to
do like an offset black in some some
form or fashion so the first thing we
want to do is change the figure the
figures face color and as we do this
I'll show you guys the change as we go
on just so you understand this like I
like the background color and so to do
that you just do face color and then
parenthesis you could do like you if you
just want a black I think B would give
you black but you can also type out
black if you wanted to do black but what
we're going to do is a hex color code
and it's me zero seven zero zero zero D
so we'll save that will run that real
quick just so you can see what I'm
talking about
so the literally the background now on
the video I don't really know how good a
quality you'll see I mean all the videos
are rendered in high-definition but it's
kind of like a dark really really dark
purplish blue
well yeah it's it like you might look at
it and think immediately it's black but
it looks better than black trust me so
whenever you use black I don't know it
just it's like - black I don't know
anyway continuing on so that's the face
color right so an absolute background of
your plot and just as a side note when
you go to save it isn't gonna save this
face color later on we're gonna have to
edit down here
and make it like save with that proper
face color so just keep that in mind if
you decide to skip my tutorial or
something so now what we want to do is
actually do like you saw like the
background of the actual chart was
unchanged so now we want to change that
so the way that we're going to do that
is say axis axis pg4 axis background and
here you can again put in any hex code
that you want and for this we're gonna
do basically I think we'll just do the
same number as we did for the figure
you'll see in a second how will
actually we're just let's just copy and
paste this in you save that we'll run
that and now it does look kind of fun oh
my goodness windows shake you're gonna
be the death of me anyway obviously this
one's still white and it's looking a
little funny we can't see our labels but
don't worry we'll get to those in a
second so that's looking good so now
we've got to move on to the candlestick
actually let's change the access
background of the volume or this the
second axis to supposed to do that so I
added that in there so now when we run
it you should see that the background is
barely see our bars but if you like
zoomed in you would see you know there's
our bars okay so now color up and color
down since we have such a dark
background we can kind of get away with
like a really light version of green and
red so for that I'm going to use this
hex code 9e ff15 and then for color down
red we're gonna use pound FF one seven
one seven
so now we'll see where we stand at the
moment so now you can see that they've
kind of like lit up a little bit right
it's a lighter red and it's a lighter
green so they really stand out with our
background so the next thing that we
want to do is as you'll notice we can't
see our grid right so you can actually
change the color of the grid so true we
want the grid and then for this let's
just make it white like just a white
grid and after that now what we want to
do I'll show you guys everything
together I think after we do this so
come down here and let's begin changing
a lot of our other stuff so first of all
we want a X 1 dot y axis dot label set
underscore color and we want to make
this white as well so this will make the
actual like labels white and we don't
really need to do the x-axis because
we've actually removed the x-axis on
this first one so there's no reason that
really change
that now what we want to do is ax 1 .
spines and as far as I know there's no
way to like just change all of the
spines at once actually well I mean I
would venture to guess that there is a
way to do it but I don't know it so
we're gonna do each one so you just do
an empty brackets for an ounce we're
gonna copy and paste this and then you
set underscore color and then in the
color we're going to use pound five
pound five nine nine eight FF that'd be
the color that we're going to set for
all the spines kind of like a light blue
so then we'll do four of these because
there's four spines and here we're gonna
do bottom and then we'll do top then
we're gonna do left and then we'll do
right and let's just go ahead and copy
this yeah we'll just copy this to the
other one as well for a x2 so just come
down to a x2 right after the grid paste
we could you could change the a x2 grid
as well to show it is like right now it
says true I'm actually gonna say ax to
grid false it's not really like it on
the volume chart it's not as essential
to like see it but anyway yeah let's
let's run it and see where we stand at
the moment over so as you can see now we
can see this label the edge of the chart
is all kind of blue or like that light
blue that I was talking about and we
have the grid on the price well at least
the candlestick so starting to look
better and now what do we want to do
let's see we probably want to do the
tick parameters we haven't really done
that yet for a x1 and going on to do the
X tick parameters because there are none
we got rid of them so a x1 dot tick
underscore params and then in the
parentheses there you have to specify
the axis and in this case we're going to
the y-axis
and then the colors that we want to do
in this case we want to do it white so
see where we stand now so you can start
to see like our numbers and all that
kind of stuff so improvement we are
always improving
now we're it to the real deal and we're
gonna kind of change up the volume like
right now we're doing bars with the
volume and there's kind of a another way
I mean you could stick with the bars if
you really like the bars but I vote that
we do something else and the way that
we're going to do this is we're going to
actually make a fill and so like you
know it's got a line and then it's
filled below the line right so the way
that you do this is you're going to
first need to know what the minimum
value is right to do a fill and later on
maybe I'll show you guys some cool
things that you can do with fill but for
now I'll just do a basic one so first
we're going to specify a variable that
tells the fill like how low - fill -
right so to do that we're gonna say
volume in equals volume document and all
this is is we're gonna use this to tell
the filler how low - fill - basically so
let's so for a X - instead of plotting a
bar just change it straight up to plot
and it's gonna plot date and volume it's
gonna plot like a date and volume line
so once once we've done that let me show
you what it looks like
so now it's like just like a straight up
line right but we want to fill this and
then we're also going to change that
line color so where date volume and what
we're going to want to do is we're gonna
change the color first of all and we'll
do pound zero zero FFP 8 and 0 0 not
oh-oh anyway and then the line weight
I'll just do like at point eight so it's
just gonna be like the tip of our fill
let's see what I mean in a second so now
we want to do is come down and now we
want to do the filler so to do a filler
just a X to build underscore between and
what do we want to fill between well we
want to fit between dates and volume in
and then act the actual volume right so
you're kind of specifying a shape and
that is our shape and then we want to
fill everything in between that shape
and then we're gonna say the color cuz
this is we're basically we're making a
shape so it has a face color right and
that color we're just gonna use the same
color is up here and then the kind of
add a little bit of an effect to it
we're gonna say alpha this is kind of
like the shade and alpha is gonna be
point five so now that we've done all
that let's draw it up so you can see
where we stand so so now you can see
that it's kind of like it's like a
filled in but even though we use the
same color since this has a low alpha
it's kind of like faded a little bit I
don't know I just kind of liked it you
could say alpha one right or no alpha
parameter and it you wouldn't have that
but I like it so anyway that's how you
do a fill and like I said you can view
all kinds of things with fill really
that's just an example so continuing on
it's to close it the next thing that we
want to do we need to specify the tick
parameters for a x2 so let's just copy
this right here and we'll paste down
twice so we're gonna this one actually
does have to paste paste and we want to
have x and y and then change this to a
x2 so save that stance now we got you
know we can see our date here we got
stock price for missing volume so we
need to add that in so close out of this
and volume here what we're going to do
is just do comma color equals W we're
gonna have to do the same thing for the
title
we could have date I'm just kind of like
not oh you can just get rid of date I
don't really think you need to call that
date right people are gonna recognize
that that's the date oops comma color
equals W for the super title there and
let's see let me see where we are at the
moment what else we need to change so
now you you know we see volume we didn't
need
and really the only changes I think we
need to make are like now that we're not
showing date here we could show it right
like we could go well I think I deleted
it yeah and you would just do color w if
you really want date there but I don't
really want it so we're not gonna have
that and so bottom instead of 18
probably 14 for that those extra
characters and then the top we're gonna
move that up just a little bit and we
don't need this anymore that was for
debugging so let's save that we'll run
it and okay so this is our chart now and
so as you can see it's kind of a line
pretty darn good now there's only one
last thing that we need to do and if you
when you close this you remember that
we're saving it to example dot PNG so if
we looked at example dot PNG you see
it's like something is wrong right it's
got this white background and the SAV
figure just automatically gives you this
like white background because if you
remember like normally it was like when
we would display it it was a grayish
background then we saved it it was like
a lovely white and it would working out
but with our new chart that's not really
working out so what we need to do is use
a function down here and so when we save
it now what we want to do is just say
face color and then you could either
just say the face color or you can just
use a get face color that way if you do
decide to change your face color ever it
just automatically changes it here like
you don't have to like do it in both
places because it's kind of
counterintuitive I'm not really sure why
that does it that way but now if you run
it you know we've got it okay cool we
close it and we open up our figure let
me make it smaller so it's on the screen
at least you'll see that okay now our
figure actually looks like we intend it
to right and so yeah that I think is
going to conclude this tutorial I'm not
really sure what else I'd want to do I
mean obviously you know it's still a
pretty interactive chart we can do
whatever we want you know you can zoom
in in various spots and you know
everything's following so
so that's going to conclude the kind of
customization of your chart I mean like
I was saying before you can change
everything as far as colors and display
are concerned you can change the fonts
even if you want I just kind of like the
fonts you could add more dates less
states you can change those so that's
pretty much going to cover all of like
the organization and kind of like
customization of the charts so hopefully
you guys have learned something
hopefully you can kind of make your
chart look however the heck you want to
make your chart look and as always
thanks for watching thank you for your
support your subscriptions and until
next time